ah
[Música]
cómo
en medio de estudios y de dudas sobre si
la vacuna desarrollada aquí en el reino
unido- por la universidad de oxford y
astrazéneca no ofrecería la protección
necesaria y suficiente contra la
variante del cómic descubierta en
sudáfrica el gobierno y los científicos
han dicho que sí que si funciona y por
ello la población debe seguir
vacunándose el subdirector médico del
gobierno ha dicho que hay evidencia
suficiente que demuestra que las vacunas
funcionan contra el virus del código
original y contra la variante que que
fue encontrada aquí en el reino unido-
que son la amenaza más cercana de hecho
en un reportaje revelado hoy por el
tabloide the sun asegura que cifras
preliminares del gobierno muestran que
las vacunas ofrecen una protección data
del 65% después de la primera dosis de
la vacuna otra de las dudas o críticas
que se han hecho sobre la vacuna de
oxford
astrazéneca es sobre si ésta funciona
para la población mayor de los
35 años los científicos y el gobierno
afirman que sí que los estudios
iniciales no se incluyó gran número de
esta población pero eso no significa
necesariamente que no opere también en
ellos
[Música]
sudáfrica ha sufrido un duro revés en la
lucha contra la pandemia apenas este mes
llegaron 1 millones de dosis de la
vacuna de astrazéneca pero un estudio
reciente de la universidad de
witwatersrand ha demostrado que esta
vacuna no es lo suficientemente eficaz
para atacar la nueva variante del virus
la variante 501 b2 identificada
inicialmente aquí en sudáfrica es más
infecciosa y es la predominante aquí en
el país y la respuesta del gobierno no
se ha hecho esperar el ministro de salud
zweli mkhize ha declarado que se
suspenderá entonces el programa de
vacunación con la vacuna de astrazéneca
pero que el programa no se suspenderá
del todo en su lugar o se usará la
vacuna johnson y johnson que según
estudios preliminares es más eficiente
contra esta nueva variante el país
espera entonces que para las próximas
semanas lleguen 9 millones de dosis de
la vacuna de johnson johnson y unos 20
millones adicionales de la vacuna de
facer el gobierno ha declarado también
que está acelerando la llegada de nuevas
dosis para empezar un programa de
vacunación que ya está de por sí
bastante en el país más
afectado por la pandemia en el
continente
[Música]
el 68% de los alemanes considera que el
proceso de vacunación en este país es
demasiado lento según una encuesta
reciente y eso es algo que las
autoridades esperan acelerar en parte
con la nueva vacuna de astrazéneca que
ya está en los diferentes estados
federados para ser distribuida a la
población más transgénica ha explicado
que hasta principios de marzo espera
entregar unos 3.2 millones de dosis pero
la vacuna de astrazéneca tiene una
particularidad aquí en alemania pues las
autoridades sanitarias en este país
explicaron que no hay evidencia
suficiente de su efectividad personas
mayores de 65 años por lo que no
recomiendan su uso en este sector de la
población ya que la vacuna de
astrazéneca vaya a ser utilizada
principalmente en personal sanitario de
cuidados intensivos o que trabajan con
adultos mayores los adultos mayores por
su parte recibirán las otras dos vacunas
que ya han sido aprobadas a nivel
europeo
[Música]